the Joe Rogan experience do you still do
used to ever take part from fans you
afraid yes yeah me too
yes just you're asking for it you are
right yeah oh I thought I'd give you a
little extra taste I put some acid out
of it for you I don't need that right my
good friend Ari Shaffir dosed Bert
Kreischer when they were doing a podcast
again so that's regal that's really
thought it was Joe now he gave him Molly
dropped it in his drink so with their
hard feelings over oh yeah there was a
real problem no it was all a joke
oh there's no jokes with us we don't do
jokes I mean I just saw it on Twitter
yeah that's real oh that shit's real no
yeah so they're not pals on their back
okay the wife hates him still Oh Bert's
wife still my kid Verizon I would have a
hard time with that yeah I only tell
issue yeah I don't you know doing
something like that you that's not right
that's that's like 40c knows he knows
it's not right what's really interesting
is I was we were just we were all joking
around about it like this is the only
business where you could dose your
friend we all joke around about it laugh
about it more nothing happens and he
actually got a bump in his career like
it starts selling out places faster and
when he was going places who you already
be doing shows and people would yell out
dose me already dosed me
so now he's known for dosing people and
before that are used to do something I
should say allegedly because what did
this this thing which may or may not
have happened is very illegal but he
would do a play in places where weed was
very legal he would play a game called
fine edible so he posted on Twitter
who'd give people hints and he would
leave some [ __ ] nuclear edible like
to some North Dakota guy who's gonna
find it who probably doesn't get any
real weed and he's gonna get one of
those stars of death and he got in
trouble I think in Minnesota oh really
allegedly because I don't think they
ever found any of the things he was
talking about so maybe it was all just a
prank
let's go with that those edibles man my
brother had something one time he goes
it's Jimmy be careful
it's called the creeper that's what they
call it and I'm like I gotta have a high
tolerance to wear so I ate one I have
like nothing so I did the I did another
one and about 45 minutes later we're at
a campground talking to my parents and
all of a sudden I can't remember how to
breathe just go I have to go make a
phone call I'm at a campground so I just
go to my car and I'm just laying down
the next thing I know I hear my wife
you're having are you okay I go I'm not
good
we have to go let's go say goodbye to
Brett I can't say goodbye let's just go
just like I couldn't deal with saying
goodbye oh my god
so yeah turns out there is some danger
to that
[Applause]